The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN DONG: All right, so I'm
sure everybody's kind of
curious about Project 2.2
Beta, so here's the
preliminary performance
results.
There's still a bit more work
to do on finalizing these
numbers, but here's
how they look.
But before I show you guys that,
I'd like to yell at you
guys for a little bit.
So this is a timeline of the
submission deadline and when
people submitted things.
So from this zone to this zone
is an hour, and I see like 50%
of the commits made during
that period.
So a little bit of background,
the submission checking system
automatically clones a
repository up to the deadline
and not a second after.
So if you look at from this
to this, some people took
quite a jump back.
So just as a warning, please try
to submit things on time.
11:59 means 11:59, and to drive
that point further, this
is an example of a commit
that I saw in somebody's
repository, who's name
I blanked out.
Obviously, it's seven seconds
past the deadline, so the
automatic repository cloner
didn't grab it.
And the previous commit to that
was like 10 days ago when
Reid pushed out pentominoes
grades.
So don't do that either.
A little break down on how
often people commit.
About a quarter of the class
only made one commit to their
repository.
Half of you guys did three
to 10 commits, which
seems to be an up.
Under 21+, there was somebody
who did 100 some commits,
which was pretty impressive.
Yeah, very smart dude.
Committing often is a good idea,
so that you don't run
into a situation like before.
And next time definitely, there
is going to be next to
zero tolerance for people who
don't commit things on time
for the deadlines.
Now, the numbers that
people want.
So for rotate, just as an
interesting data point, this
is the 512 by 512 case.
It seems like not everybody
remembered to carry over their
optimizations for the 512 case
over to the final, otherwise
you would expect the numbers
to be a little bit more
similar and not off by
a factor of eight.
And for rotate overall, that's
the distribution.
The speed up factor is
normalized to some constant
that gives everybody a
reasonable number.
And there were a lot
of groups that had
code that didn't build.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does the speedup
only include
the rotate dot 64.
JOHN DONG: Yes.
Performance was only tested on
the rotate dot 64, which is
what we said in the
handout also.
So there were a lot of groups
that didn't build, which
really surprised me, and I think
it's probably because
half of you guys pushed things
after the deadline, and I
presume those things contained
important commits towards
making your code
actually work.
But in this case, there was no
header files, there was no
cross-testing.
All we did was run your make
file on your code, and we
replaced your test bed dot c,
and your k timing, so I'm not
quite sure why people have
code that doesn't build.
For sort, this was the maximum
size input that we allowed you
guys to run.
One group did really well.
So all of these are correct.
The correctness test is built
in, and I replaced that with a
clean copy that contains
a couple additional
checks, by the way.
So I tried the other extreme,
a relatively small array.
AUDIENCE: Is the top
the same person?
JOHN DONG: I'm not sure whether
or not the top is the
same person.
But the distribution wise seems
like people didn't quite
remember to optimize for
the smallest case.
And this is the current overall
speedup factors for
sort averaging.
We did about 10 to 15 cases
for rotate and sort.
And that's the overall
speedup distribution.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK, so now
you're done with individual
project, so you already did the
last project individually,
and then we are moving into,
again, a group project.
So the first thing we have,
setting up automated system
for you to say who your
group members are.
So we will send you information,
and with that,
what you have to do is run a
script saying who your group
members are, both group members
have to do it, and
then we will basically clear
that account in there.
That said, a lot of you didn't
know, in the first project,
how to work and what's
the right mode of
operations with the group.
OK if we gave you to write
100,000 lines of code, it
makes sense to say, OK, I'm
going to divide the problem
into half, one person do
one, the other person
do the other half.
The reason for doing the group
is to try to get you to do
pair programming, because
talking to a lot of you,
getting a lot of feedback, it
looks like most of you spent a
huge amount of time debugging.
And since you're only writing
a little amount of code, it
makes a lot more sense to sit
with your partner next to the
screen, one person types, other
person looks over, and
then you have a much faster
way of getting through the
debugging process.
So the next one, don't try to
divide the problem by half.
Just try to find some time,
sit with each other.
Then the other really disturbing
thing is there have
been a couple of groups that
were completely dysfunctional.
We get emails saying, OK, my
group member didn't talk to
me, or they didn't do any
work, or they were very
condescending.
And that's really sad, because
from my experience with MIT
students, when you guys go to
company, you guys probably
will be the best programmers
there.
There's no question about it.
I have seen that.
To the point that some people
might even resent it, to have
this best programmer.
But what I have seen is the fact
a lot of you cannot work
in the group, if you haven't
developed that skill, you will
not be the most impactful
person.
I have seen that again and again
in my experience with
doing a start-up.
Our MIT students, their way of
impacting is put all night do
the entire project
by themselves.
Doable when you're doing a
small change to a large
project, but if you want
to have a big change,
you can't do that.
You have to work with the
group, figure out how to
impact, how to communicate.
This is more important learning
than, say, trying to
figure out how you can
optimize something.
So being individual contributors
and able to do
amazing things is important,
but the fact that you can't
work with a group is going to
really make the impact you can
make much less.
So please, please learn how to
work with your group members.
Some of them might not be as
good as you are, and that will
be probably true in real life,
too, but that doesn't mean you
can be condescending towards
them, make them feel inferior.
That doesn't cut it.
You have to learn how to
work with these people.
So part of your learning is
working with others, and
that's a large part
of your learning.
Don't consider that to be this
external thing, even though
you might think you can
do a better job.
Just work with the other person,
especially in pair
programming, because where
both of you are sticking
together, it's much easier.
Because there are four eyes on
your project, they might see
something you don't see, and
see whether you can work
together like that.
And I don't want to hear any
more stories saying, look, my
partner was too dumb, or my
partner didn't show up, he
couldn't deal with that.
Those are not great excuses.
And so we wonder.
Some of them, we will pay
attention to it, because it
might be one person's
unilateral actions
that lead to that.
Still, please, try to figure
out how we can
work with your partners.
And hope you have a good
partner experience.
Use pair programming.
Use a lot of good debugging
techniques, and the next
project will be fine.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Great.
We're going to talk
more about caches.
Whoo-whoo!
OK.
So for those who weren't here
last time, we talked about the
ideal cache model.
As you recall, it has a
two-level hierarchy and a
cache size M bytes, and a cache
line length of B bytes.
It's fully associative
and is optimal
omniscient replacement strategy.
However, we also learned that
LRU was a good substitute, and
that any of the asymptotic
results that you can get with
optimal, you could also
get with LRU.
The two performance measures
that we talked about were the
work, which deals with what the
processor ends up doing,
and the cache misses, which is
the transfers between cache
and main memory.
You only have to count one
direction, because what goes
in basically goes out, so more
or less, it's the same number.
OK, so I'd like to start today
by talking about some very
basic algorithms that you have
seen in your algorithms and
data structures class, but which
may look new when we
start taking caches
into account.
So the first one here
is the problem of
merging two sorted arrays.
So as you recall, you
can basically do
this in linear time.
The way that the algorithm works
is that it looks at the
first element of the two
arrays to be sorted and
whichever is smaller, it
puts in the output.
And then it advances the pointer
to the next element,
and then whichever is smaller,
it puts in the output.
And in every step, it's doing
just a constant amount of
work, there are n items, so by
the time this process is done,
we basically spent time
proportional to the number of
items in the output list.
So this should be
fairly familiar.
So the time to emerge n
elements is order n.
Now, the reason merging is
useful is because you can use
it in a sorting algorithm, a
merge sorting algorithm.
The way merge sort works is it
essentially does divide and
conquer on the array.
It divides the array into two
pieces, and it divides those
each into two pieces, and those
into two, until it gets
down to something
of unit size.
And then what it does
is it merges the
two pairs of arrays.
So for example here, the 19 and
3 got merged together to
be 3 and 19.
The 12 and 46 were already in
order, but you still had to do
work to get it there
and so forth.
So it puts everything in order
in pairs, and then for each of
those, it puts it together into
fours, and for each of
those, it puts it together
into the final list.
Now of course, the way it does
this is not in the order I
showed you.
It actually goes down and does
a walk of this tree.
But conceptually, you can see
that it essentially comes down
to merging pairs, merging
quadruples, emerging octuples,
and so forth, all the way until
the program is done.
So to calculate the work of
Merge Sort, this is something
you've seen before because it's
exactly what you do in
your algorithms class.
You get a recurrence that
says that the work,
in this case is--
well, if you have only one
element, it's a constant
amount of work, and otherwise,
I solve two problems of half
the size doing order n work,
which is the time to merge the
two elements.
So classic divide and conquer.
And I'm sure you're familiar
with what the solution to this
recurrence is.
What's the solution to
this recurrence?
n log n.
I want to, though, step through
it, just to get
everybody warmed up to the
way that I want to solve
recurrences so that you are in
a position, when we do the
caching analysis--
we have a common framework for
understanding how the caching
analysis will work.
So we're going to solve this
recurrence, and if the base
case is constant, we
usually omit it.
It's assumed.
So we start out with W of n, and
what we do is we replace
it by the right hand side, where
we put the constant term
on the top and then
the two children.
So here I've gotten rid of the
theta, because conceptually
when I'm done, I can put a big
theta around the whole thing,
around the whole tree, and it
just makes the math a little
bit easier and a little
bit clearer to see
what's going on.
So then I take each of those
and I split those, and this
time I've got n over 4.
Correct?
I checked for that
one this time.
It's funny because it was still
there, actually, just a
few minutes before class
as I was going through.
And we keep doing that until
we get down to something of
size one, until the recurrence
bottoms out.
So when you look at a recursion
tree of this nature,
the first thing that you
typically want to do is take a
look at what the height
of the tree is.
In this case, we're taking a
problem of size n, and we're
halving it at every step.
And so the number of times we
have to halve the argument--
which turns out to be also equal
to the work, but that's
just coincidence--
is log n times.
So the height is log
base 2 of n.
Now what we do typically is we
add things up across the rows,
across the levels.
So on the top level,
we have n.
On the next level, we have n.
The next level, hey, n.
To add up the bottom, just to
make sure, we have to count up
how many leaves there are, and
the number of leaves, since
this is a binary tree, is
just 2 to the height.
So it's 2 to the log
n, which is n.
So then I add across all the
leaves, and I get the order 1
at the base times n,
which is order n.
And so now I'm in a position
to add up the total work,
which is basically log n
levels of n is total
of order n log n.
So hopefully, this
is all review.
Hopefully this is all review.
You haven't seen this before.
It's really neat, isn't it?
But you've missed something
along the way.
So now with caching.
So the first thing to observe is
that merge subroutine, the
number of cache misses that it
has is order n over B. So as
you're going through, these
arrays are laid out
continuously in memory.
The number of misses--
you're just going through
the data once--
is order n data, all going
through contiguously.
And so every time you bring in
data, you get full spatial
locality, there are n elements,
it costs n over B.
So is that plain?
Hopefully that part's plain,
because you bring in things of
each axis, you get the
same factor of B.
So now merge sort--
and this is, once again, the
hard part is coming up with a
recurrence, and then the other
hard part is solving it.
So there's two hard parts
to recurrences.
OK, so the merge sort algorithm
solves two problems
of size n over 2, and
then does a merge.
So the second line here is
pretty straightforward.
I take the cache misses
that I need to do,
and I take a merge.
I may have a few other accesses
in there, but they're
going to be dominated
by the merge.
OK, so it's still going
to be theta n over B.
Now the hard part, generally, of
dealing with cache analysis
is how to do the base case,
because the base case is more
complicated than when you just
do running time, you get that
to run down to a base case
of constant size.
Here, you don't get to
run down to base
case of constant size.
So what it says here is that
we're going to run down until
I have a sorting problem that
fits in cache, n is going to
be less than some constant times
n, for some sufficiently
small constant c less than 1.
When in finally fits in cache,
how many cache misses does it
take me to sort it?
Well, I only need to have the
cold misses to bring that
array into memory, and so that's
just proportional to n
over B, because for all the rest
of the levels of merging,
you're inside the cache.
That make sense?
So that's where we get
this recurrence.
This is always a tricky thing
to figure out how to write
that recurrence for
a given thing.
Then, as I say, the other
tricky thing is how
do you solve it?
But we're going to solve it
essentially the same way as we
did before.
I'm not going to go through all
the steps here, except to
just elaborate.
So what we're doing is we're
taking, and we have n over B
at the top, and then we divide
it into two problems, and for
each of those--
whoops, there's a c there
that doesn't belong.
It should just be n over
2B on both, and then n
over 4B, and so forth.
And we keep going down until
we get to our base case.
Now in our base case, what I
claim is that when I hit this
base case, it's going to be the
case that n is, in fact, a
constant factor times n, so that
n over B is almost the
same as m over B. And the reason
is because before I hit
the base case, when I was at
size twice n, and that was
bigger than m.
So if twice n is
bigger than m--
than my constant times m--
but n is smaller than m, then
it's the case that n and m are
essentially the same size to
within a constant factor,
within a factor of
two, in fact.
And so therefore, here I can say
that it's order m over B.
And now the question is, how
many levels did I have to go
down cutting things in half
before I got to something of
size m over B?
Well, the way that I usually
think about this is--
you can do it by taking the
difference as I did before.
The height of the whole tree is
going to be log base 2 of
n, and the height of this
is basically log of--
what's the size of n?
It's going to be log of the size
of n when this occurs.
Well, n at that point is
something like cm.
So it's basically log n minus
log cm, which is basically log
of n over cm.
How about some questions.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: --the reason for why
you just substituted on the
left, [INAUDIBLE] over B, but
on the right [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Here?
AUDIENCE: No.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Or you mean here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: On
the right side.
AUDIENCE: On the right-most
leaf, it's n over B. Is that
all of the leaves added up
because [INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: No, no, no,
this is going to be all of the
leaves added up here.
This is the stack I have
on the right hand side.
So we'll get there.
So the point is, the number of
leaves is 2 to this-- so
that's just n over cm--
times m over B. Well, n over
cm times m over B, the m's
cancel, and I get essentially
n over b with whatever that
constant is here.
And so now I have n over b
across every level, and then
when I add those up, I have to
go log of n over cm levels,
which is the same as
log of n over m.
So I have n over B times
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Initial assumption
that c is some sufficiently
small number, so 1
over c would be a
rather large factor.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It could
potentially be a large factor,
but it's a constant.
In other words, it can't
vary with n.
So in fact, typically for
something like merge sort, the
constant is going to
be very close to--
for most things, the constant
there is typically only a few.
Because the question is, how
many other things do you need
in order to make sure
it fits in?
In this case, you have n.
Well, you have both the input
and the output, so here, it's
going to be, you have to fit
both the input and the output
into cache in order not
to have the cache it.
So it's basically going
to be like a factor
of 2 for merge sort.
For the matrix multiplication,
it was like a factor of three.
So generally a fairly
small number.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I guess that
makes sense.
But I [INAUDIBLE].
So on the order of the size of
the leaves, can you assume
that n is more than cm, so
you can substitute--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, because
basically, when it
hits this condition--
AUDIENCE: Right.
I understand that.
Then you're also saying, why
isn't there more or less just
one B, because there's n over
cm, n is the same as cm.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
At the bottom level,
there should be--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Oh, did I
do something wrong here?
Number of leaves is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Right, right.
Sorry.
This is the n at the top.
You always have to
be careful here.
So this is the n in this case,
so this is some n, little n.
So this is not the same n.
This is the n that we
had at the top.
This is the notion of
recurrences, like the n keeps
recurring, but you
know which ones--
so it can be confusing,
because if you're--
so yeah.
So this is not the
n that's here.
This is the n that started
out at the top.
So we're analyzing it
in terms of the n.
Some people write these things
where they would write this in
terms of k, and then analyze it
for n, and for some people,
that can be helpful to do, to
disambiguate the two things.
I always find it wastes a
variable, and you know, those
variables are hard to come by.
There's only a finite
number of them.
OK, so are we good for this?
So here, we ended up with
n over b, log of n
over m cache misses.
So how does that compare?
Let's just do a little
thinking about this.
Here's the recurrence, and
I solved it out to this.
So let's just look to
see what this means.
If I have a really big n, much
bigger than the size of my
cache, then I'm going to do a
factor of B log n less misses
than work, because the work
is n over B log n.
So if n compared to m-- let's
say n was m squared or
something--
then n over m would
still be n, if n
was as big as m squared.
So if n was as big as m squared,
this log of n over m
would still be log n.
And so I would basically have n
over B log n for a factor of
B log n less misses than work.
If they're about the same--
did I get this right?
If they're about the same size,
if n is approximately m,
maybe it's just a little bit
bigger, then the log here
disappears completely, and
so I basically just
have n over B misses.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
but if n is like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
In fact, for this, you have to
be careful as you get to the
base cases.
Technically, for some of this,
I should be saying 1 plus log
of n over m, and in some of the
things I do later, I will
put in the ones.
But if you're looking at it
asymptotically and n gets big,
you don't have to worry
about those cases.
That just handles the case
whether you're looking at n
getting large or whether you're
trying to handle a
formula for all n, even
if and n is small.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: The work
was n log n, yes.
The work was n log n.
So here we basically have n over
B log n, so I'm saving a
factor of B in the case where
it's about the same.
Did I get this right?
I'm just looking at this, and
now I'm trying to reverse
engineer what my argument is.
So we're looking at n log n
versus n over B log n over m.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
So that you get a factor of B
less misses, because you would
be getting n over B like log
of n, that's the only way
you're getting a factor
of B less misses.
So I don't understand how you're
saying, for n more or
less equal to m.
You would want something
more like, for n--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Well, if n
and m are about the same size,
the number of cache misses is
just n over B. And the number
of cache misses is n over B,
and the work is n log n.
So I've saved a factor
of B times log n, OK?
What did I say?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: B log m?
No, I was saying that's
for the case when n is
much bigger than m.
So let's take a look
at the case--
let me just do it on
the board here.
Let's suppose that n is like m
squared, just as an example,
big number.
So I'm going to look at,
essentially, n over B times
log of n over m.
So log of n over m, so what is
n over m is about m, which is
about square root of n, right?
So this basically ends up being
approximately n over B
log of square root of n, which
is the same as log n, to
within a constant factor.
I'm going to leave out the
constant factors here.
Then I want to compare
that with n log n.
So I get a factor of
B less misses.
So the first one, yes, OK.
So I get a factor of B less
misses, you're right.
Then I get a factor
of B less misses.
So I think I've got
these switched.
So this is the case I'm doing
is for n much bigger than m.
So let's do the other case.
I think I've got the two
things switched.
I'll fix it in the notes.
If n and m are approximately
the same, then the log is a
constant, right?
So this ends up being
approximately n over B. And
now when I take a look at the
difference between the number
of things, I get B log n.
So I've got the two
things mixed.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: As n approaches m,
then the log would approach
zero, but were you talking
about how it technically
should be--
CHARLES LEISERSON:
1 plus n, yes.
AUDIENCE: So technically, that
approaches one when the log
approaches zero.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: These things are
really hard for me, because
they are really arbitrary.
And then you're like, oh
yeah, you can just put
a 1 on top of there.
And for example, I always miss
those, because I usually try
to do the math as rigorously
as I can, and those ones
generally do not appear,
and you're
like, oh, sure whatever.
So how am I supposed to know
that the log is actually not
going to be zero, and I'm going
to be like, yeah, you're
not going to do any caches.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Because
generally, what we're doing is
we're looking at how things
scale, so we're generally
looking at n being big, in which
case it doesn't matter.
These things only matter if
n's-- for example, notice here
that if n goes less than m,
we're in real trouble, right?
Because now the log
is negative.
Wait, what does that mean?
Well, the answer is the analysis
was assuming that n
was sufficiently large
compared with m.
AUDIENCE: Why can't you just
be like, oh, when n is for
less than one, you can assume,
well, n is 2n.
In that case, you get log
of two, which is still
something or other.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, exactly.
So what happens in these things
is if you get right on
the cusp of fitting in memory,
then these analyses like,
well, what exactly is the
answer, is dicey.
But if you assume that
it doesn't fit in,
what's going to happen?
Or that does fit in, what
is going to happen?
And then the analysis
right on the edge is
somewhere between there.
Good.
So I switched these.
I said this the other
way around.
That's funny.
I went through this, and then
in my notes, I had them
switched, and I said, oh my
gosh, I did this wrong.
And I've just gone through it,
and it turns out I was right
in my notes.
Now, one of the things, if you
look at what's going on--
let's just go back to
this picture here.
What's going on here is each one
of the passes that we're
doing to do a merge is basically
taking n over B
misses to do a binary merge.
We're going through all the data
to merge just two things,
and traversing all the data.
So you can imagine, what would
happen if I did, say, a
four-way merge?
With a four-way merge, I could
actually merge four things
with only a little bit more
than n over B misses.
In fact, that's what we're going
to analyze in general.
So the idea is that we can
improve our cache efficiency
by doing multi-way merging.
So the idea here is, let's merge
R, which is, let's say,
less than n subarrays
with a tournament.
So here are R subarrays, and
here's they're each, let's
say, is of size n over R. And
what we're going to do is
merge them with a tournament, so
this is a tournament where
we say, who's the winner of
these two, who's the winner of
these two, et cetera.
And then whoever wins at the top
here, we take them and put
them in the output, and then
we repeat the tournament.
Now let's just look
what happens.
It takes order R work to produce
the forced output.
So we got R things here.
To playoff this tournament,
there are R nodes here.
They each have to do a constant
amount of comparing
before I end up with a single
value to put in the output.
So it costs me R to get
this thing warmed up.
But once I find the winner,
and I remove the winner
whatever chain he might have
come along, how quickly can I
repopulate the tournament
with the next guy?
The next guy only has to play
the tournament on the path
that was there.
All the other matches,
we know who won.
So the second guy only cost me
log R to produce the next guy.
And the next guy is log R, and
so once we get going, to do an
R-way merge only costs me
log R work per element.
So the total work in merging is
R, to get started, plus n
log R. Well, R is less than n,
so that's just n log R total
to do the merging.
That's the work.
Now, let's take a look at what
happens if I now do merge sort
with R-way merges.
So what I do is if I have only
one element, then it's going
to cost me order one time to
merge it, because there's
nothing to do, just put
it in the output.
Otherwise, I've got R problems
of size n over R that I'm
going to merge, and my
merge takes n log R
time to do the merge.
So if I look at the recursion
tree, I have n log R here
starting here, then I branch R
ways, and then I have n over R
log R to do the R-way branching
at the next level, n
over R squared log R at the
next level, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: You said that the
cost of processing is R.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
--is n log R.
AUDIENCE: But is--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Upfront,
there's an order R cost, but
the order R cost is dominated
by the n log R, so we don't
have to count that separately.
We just have to worry
about this guy.
So as I go through here, I
basically end up having a tree
which is only log base R of n
tall, because I'm dividing
things into R pieces
each time, rather
than into two pieces.
So I only go log base R steps
till I get to the base case.
But I'm doing an R-way merge,
so the number of
leaves is still n.
But now when I add across here,
I get n times log R, and
I go across here, I get n times
log R, because I got R
copies of the same thing.
Now I've got R squared times
n over R squared
log R, and so forth.
And so at every level, I have
n log R. So I have n log R
times the number of levels here,
which is log base R of
n, plus the order n work at
the bottom, which we can
ignore because it's going
to be dominated.
And so what you notice here is,
what's log base R of n?
That's just log n over log R.
So the log Rs cancel, and I
get n log n plus n, which
is just n log n.
So after all that work, we still
do the same amount of
work, whether I do binary
merging or R-way merging, the
work is the same.
But there's kind of
a big difference
when it comes to caching.
So it's the same work as
binary merge sort.
So let's take a look
at the caching.
So let's assume that my
tournament fits in the cache.
So I want to make sure that R is
less than m over B for some
constant R. So when I do
constant way, when I consider
the R-way merging of contiguous
arrays of total
size n, the entire tournament
plus 1 block from each array
can fit in cache.
So the tournament is never going
to be responsible for
generating cache misses, because
I'm going to leave the
tournament in memory.
So if I'm the optimal algorithm,
it's going to say,
let's just leave the tournament
in memory and bring
in all the other things as
we do the operation.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Those circles
that I had, the tree.
AUDIENCE: Is that a cumulative
list of the elements that
you've merged in already?
CHARLES LEISERSON: I'm sorry.
Is the--
AUDIENCE: Is it a cumulative
list of the length arrays that
you've merged already?
CHARLES LEISERSON: No, no, no.
You haven't merged them.
Let's just go back
and make sure we
understand the algorithm.
The algorithm says that what we
do is we compare the head
of this pair and we produce a
single value here, for which
whatever is-- because
these are already
sorted to do the merge.
These are already sorted.
So I just have the minimum of
these two here, and the
minimum of these two here,
and the minimum of all
four of them here.
So it's repeated.
When we get to the top, we have
now the minimum of all of
these guys, and that's the guy
that's the minimum overall, we
put him in the output array.
And now we walk back down the
path that he came from, and
what we do is we say, oh, this
guy had a-- let's walk down
the path, let's say we
get to this guy.
Let's advance the pointer
in here and
bring out another element.
And now we play off the
tournament here, play off the
guy here, and he advances, and
he advances, whatever.
And now some other path
may be the minimum.
But it only took
me log n work.
I'm only keeping copies of the
element, if you will, or the
results of the comparisons along
this in the tree here.
And that tree, we're saying,
fits in the cache, plus 1
block, the first block.
Whatever cache block fits in
each of these arrays, no
matter how much we've gone
down, one of those
is fitting in memory.
So then what happens here is the
entire tournament plus one
block from each memory can fit
in cache, and so therefore the
number of cache misses that I'm
going to have when I do
the merge it's just essentially
the time to take
faults on that one cache block
whenever I exceed it in each
array, plus the one for the
output that's similar.
And so the total number of cache
misses that I'm going to
have is going to be n over B,
because I'm just striding
straight through memory, and
that tournament, I don't have
to worry about, because
it's sitting in cache.
And there's enough sitting in
cache that all the other
stuff, I can just keep one block
from each of them in
memory and still expect
to get it.
In fact, you need the tall cache
assumption to assume
that they all fit in memory.
So therefore, the R-way merge
sort is then, if it's
sufficiently small, once again,
we have the case that
it fits in memory so I only have
the cold misses to get
there, n over B, if
n is less than cm.
And otherwise, it's R copies of
the number of cache misses
for n over R, plus n over B.
Because this is what it took
us here to do the merge.
We get only n over B faults when
we merge, as long as the
tournament fits in cache.
If the tournament doesn't fit
in cache, it's a more
complicated analysis.
AUDIENCE: --n over B,
that's cold misses.
You're getting the stuff--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
basically, it's the cold
misses on the data,
yes, basically.
Good.
So now, let's do the recursion
tree for this.
So we basically have n over B
that we're going to pay at
every level, dividing by R, et
cetera, down to the point
where things fit in cache.
And by the time it fits in
cache, it's going to be m over
B, because n will be
approximately m, just as we
had before when we were
doing the binary case.
As soon as the subarray
completely fits in memory, I
don't have to when I'm
doing the sorting.
So this is now analyzing not the
merging, this is analyzing
the sorting now.
This is the sorting,
not the merging.
So we get down to m over B, and
I've gone now log base R,
not log base 2 as we
did before, but log
base R n over cm.
The number of leaves is n over
cm, and so when I multiply
this out, I get the same n over
B here, and I've got n
over B at every level here.
So where's the win?
The win is that I have only
log base R of n over cm,
rather than log base 2 levels
in the tree, because the
amount that every level
cost me was the same,
asymptotically.
So when I add it up, I get n
over B log base R of n over m,
instead of n over B log
base 2 of n over m.
So how do we tune R?
Well if we just look at this
formula here, if I want to
tune R, what should I
do to R to make this
be as small as possible?
Make it as big as possible.
But I had to assume that R was
less than some constant times
m so that it fits in cache.
So that's, in fact, what I do,
is I say R is m over B. So it
fits in cache, we have at least
one block for each thing
that we're merging.
And then when we do the analysis
now, I take log base
m over B here, and that's
compared to the binary one,
which was log base 2, which is
a factor of-- because this is
just log 2 over log base--
of log of m over B savings
in cache misses.
Now, is that a significant
number?
Let's take a look.
So if your l one cache is 32
kilobytes, and we have cache
lines of 64 bytes, that is
basically the difference in
the exponents, 9x savings.
For l two cache, we get
about a 12x savings.
For l three, we get about
a 17x savings.
Now of course, there are some
other constants going on in
here, so you can't be absolutely
sure that it's
exactly these numbers, but it's
going to be proportional
to these numbers.
So that's pretty good savings
to do multi-way merging.
So generally when you merge,
don't merge pairs.
Not a very good way of doing
it if you want to take good
advantage of cache.
May give you some ideas for how
to improve some sorts that
you might have looked at.
Now it turns out that there's
a cache oblivious sorting
algorithm, where you don't
actually have--
that was a cache aware algorithm
that knew the size
of the cache, and we tune
R to get there.
There is an algorithm called
funnelsort, which is based on
recursively sorting and
n to the 1/3 groups of
n to the 2/3 items.
And then you merge the sorted
groups with a merging process
called an n to the 1/3 funnel.
So this is more for fun,
although the sorting
algorithm, in my experience,
from what others have told me
about implementing it and so
forth, is probably about 30%
slower than the best hand-tuned
algorithm.
Whereas with matrix
multiplication, the cache
oblivious algorithms are as
good as any cache aware
algorithm as a practical matter,
here, they're off by
about 20% or 30%.
So interesting research topic
is build one of these things
and make it really efficient
so that it can compete with
real sorts.
So the k funnel merges k cubed
items in k sorted lists,
incurring this many
cache funnels.
Here, I did put in the one, for
people who are concerned
about the ones.
And so then, you get this
recurrence for the cache
misses, because you solve n to
the 1/3 problems of size n to
the 2/3 recursively, plus
this amount for merging.
And that ends up giving you this
bound, which turns out to
be asymptotically optimal.
And the way it works is there's
basically, a k funnel
is constructed recursively.
And the idea is that what we
have is, we have recursive k
funnels, so this is going to be
a merging process, that is
going to produce k cubed items
by having k to the 3/2 buffers
that each are taking the square
root of k guys and
producing k guys out.
So each of these guys is going
to produce k, and the square
root of k of them for a total
of k to the 3/2, but each of
these is going to be length
square root of k, so we end up
with k cubed.
and And they basically feed each
other, and then they get
merged with their own k thing,
and each of these then
recursively is constructed
the same way.
And the basic idea is that you
keep filling the buffers, I
think I say this here, so that
all these buffers end up being
in contiguous storage.
And the idea is, rather than
going and just getting one
element out as you do in a
typical tournament, as long as
you're going to go merge, let's
merge a lot of stuff and
put it into our buffer
so we don't have to
go back here again.
So you sort of batch your
merging in local regions, and
that ends up using the
cache efficiently
in the local regions.
Enough of sorting.
Let's go on to physics.
So many of you are probably
studying in your linear
algebra class or elsewhere,
the heat equation.
So, people familiar with
heat diffusion?
So it's a common one to
do, and these were--
I have a former student,
Matteo Frigo, who is a
brilliant coder on anything
cache oblivious.
He's got the best
code out there.
So the 2D heat equation, what we
do is let's let u(t, x, y)
be the temperature at time
t at point (x, y).
And now you can go through the
physics and come up with an
equation that looks like this,
which says that basically the
partial of u with respect to t
is proportional to the sum of
the second partials with
respect to x and
with respect to y.
So basically what that says is,
the hotter the difference
between two things, the quicker
things are going to
adjust, the quicker
the temperature
moves between them.
And alpha is the thermal
diffusivity, which has--
different materials have
different thermal
diffusivities.
Say that three times fast.
So if we do a simulation, we
can end up with heats, say,
put like this, and after
it looks like this.
See if we can get this
running here.
So now, let me see.
So I can move my cursor around
and make things.
You can just sort of see
that it simulates.
You can see the simulation
is actually pretty slow.
Now, on my slide, I have a
thing here that says--
let's see if this breaks
when we do it again.
There we go.
So we're getting around 100
frames per minute in doing
this simulation.
And so how does this
simulation work?
So let's take a look at that.
It's kind of a neat problem.
So this is what happened
when I did 6.172
for a little while.
It basically gave me that after
a while, because it just
sort of averages things,
smears it out.
So what's going on?
Let's look at it in one
dimension, because it's easier
to understand than if we
take on two dimensions.
So assuming that we have,
say, a bar which has no
differential in this direction,
only in this direction.
So then we get to drop the
partials with respect to y.
So if I take a look at that,
what I can do is what's called
a finite difference
approximation, which you probably--
who's studied finite
differences?
So a few people.
It's OK if you haven't.
That's OK if you haven't, I'll
teach it to you now.
And then you're free to forget
it, because that's not the
part that I want you to
understand, but it is
interesting.
So what I can do is look at the
partial, for example, with
respect to t, and just do an
approximation the says, well,
let me perturb t
a little bit--
that's what it means.
So I add delta t minus u of t
divided by t plus delta t
minus t, which gives
me delta t.
And I can use that as an
approximation for this partial.
Then on the right hand side--
well first of all, let me get
the first derivative
with respect to x.
And basically here what I'll do
is I'll do an approximation
where I take x plus delta x over
2 minus x minus delta x
over 2, and once again, the
differences in the terms there
ends up being delta x.
And now I use that to
take the next one.
So basically, to take this
one, I basically take the
partial with respect to delta
x over 2, minus the partial
with x minus delta x over 2, and
take the partial of that,
do the approximation.
And what happens is, if you
look at it, when I take a
partial here I'm adding delta
x over 2 twice, so I end up
getting just a delta x here,
and then the two things on
either side combined give me my
original one, 2 times u(t,
x), and then another one here,
and now the whole thing over
delta x squared.
And so what I can do is to
reduce this heat equation,
which is continuous, to
something that we can handle
in a computer, which is
discrete, by saying OK, let's
just do this approximation that
says that this term must
be equal to that term.
And if you've studied the linear
algebra that said that
there are all kinds of
conditions on convergence, and
stability, and stuff like that,
that are actually quite
interesting from a numerical
point of view, but we're not
going to get into it.
But basically, I've just taken
that equation here and said,
OK, that's my approximation
for this one.
And now what do I have here?
I've got u of t plus delta t,
and u things u of t, and then
over here, they're all with t,
but now the deltas are in--
whoops, that should have
been a delta x there.
I don't know how
that got there.
That should be a
delta x there.
They're all in spatial
over here.
So what I can do is take this,
and do an iterative process to
compute this.
And so the idea is, let me take
this and throw this term
onto the right hand side, and
look at u of t plus delta t as
if it's t plus 1.
Let me make my delta be
one, essentially.
Throw the delta t over here
times the alpha over delta x1,
and then I get basically u of
tx is based on u of t of x
plus 1 and of x and x minus 1.
As I say, there's a typo here.
That should be a delta t.
So what that says is that if I
look at my one-dimensional
process proceeding through
time, what I'm doing is
updating every point here based
on the three points
below it, diagonally
to the right, and
diagonally to the left.
So this guy can be updated
because of those.
These we're not going update,
because they're the boundary.
So these can be fixed.
In a periodic stencil,
they may even wrap
around like a torus.
So basically, I can go through
and update all these with
whatever that hairy
equation is.
And this is basically what
the code is that I
showed you is doing.
It just keeps updating everyone
based on three until
I've gone through a bunch of
time, and that's how the
system evolves.
So any questions about
how I got to here?
So we're going to now
look at this purely
computer sciencey now.
We don't have to understand
any of those equations.
We just have to understand
the structure.
The structure is that we're
updating t plus 1 based on
stuff on three points with
some function that some
physicist oracle gave
us out of the blue.
And so here is a pretty simple
algorithm to do it.
I basically have what's called
the kernel, which does this
updating, basically updating
each one based on things.
And what I'm going to do for
computer science is I don't
need to keep all the
intermediate values.
And so what I'm going
to do is do what's
called an even-odd trick.
Basically if I have one row,
I compute the next row into
another array, and then I'll
reuse that first array-- it's
all been used up--
and go back to the first one.
So basically here, I'm just
going to update t plus 1 mod
2, and just allocate two arrays
of size n, and just do
modding all the way up.
Is that clear?
And other than that, it's
basically doing the same
thing, and I'm doing a little
bit of fancy arithmetic here
by passing--
see stuff, where I'm passing the
pointer to where I am in
the array, so I only
have to update it
locally within the array.
So I don't have to double
indexing once I'm in the
array, because I'm already
indexed into the part of the
array that I'm going to use, and
then I am doing flipping.
So this is just a little
bit of cleverness.
You might want to study
this later.
So what's happening then is I
have this double nested loop
where I have a time loop on the
outside, and a space loop
on the inside, and I'm basically
going through and
using a stencil of this shape,
this is called a three point
stencil, because you're
basically taking three points
to update one point.
And now if I imagine that this
dimension is bigger, n here is
bigger than my cache size,
what's going to happen?
I'm going to take a cache fault
here, these are all cold
misses, et cetera.
But when I get back to the
beginning here, if I use LRU,
nothing is going to be in memory
that I happened to
update over here.
So I have to go and I
take a cache fault
on every cache line.
And so if I'm going t steps into
the future from where I
started, I basically have n
times t updates, and I save a
factor of B, because I get the
spatial locality because the u
of t minus 1, u of t, and u of t
plus 1, are all generally on
the same-- are nearby, and all
within one cache line.
Question?
AUDIENCE: The x's, what
are the x's for?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Sorry.
I should have put the
legend on here.
The x's are a miss.
So I do a miss when I update
these, and then these I don't
miss on, because it
was brought in
when I accessed that.
And then I do a miss,
and I'll do it--
so basically I do it, then I
shift over the stencil by one,
and then I won't get a miss.
So I'm just looking at the
misses on the reads, not
misses on the writes.
I should have made
that clear, too.
But the point is, the writes
don't help you, because it's
all out of memory by the
time I get up here.
To the second row, if this is
longer than my cache size,
none of that's there
if I'm using LRU.
AUDIENCE: You have also a miss,
like you need to get two
[INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, but
what I'm saying is I'm only
looking at the read misses.
Yes, there are write misses as
well, but basically, I'm only
doing the read misses.
You can look at the write
misses as well.
It makes the picture messier.
So we've basically
have nt over b.
However this, let me tell
you, is the way that
everybody codes it.
and And if you have a machine
where you have any bandwidth
issues to memory, especially for
these large problems, this
is not a very good way to
do it, as it turns out.
So it turns out that what you
want to do is, as we've seen,
divide and conquer is a really
good way to do it.
But in this case, when we're
doing divide and conquer,
we're actually not going to use
rectangles, we're going to
use trapezoids.
And the reason is that a
trapezoid has the nice
property that--
notice that if I have all these
points in memory, then
notice that I can compute all
the guys that are read on the
next level, and then I can
compute all the guys that are
next on the next level.
And so for example, if you
imagine that this part here
fit within cache, I could
actually keep going.
I didn't have to stop here, I
could keep going right up to a
triangle if I wanted to, and
compute all the values without
having any more cache misses
than those needed to bring in,
essentially, one row--
two rows, actually, because
I'm reusing the
rows as I go up.
So what we're going to do is
traverse trapezoidal regions
of space-time points such that
the points are between an
upper limit, T1, and a low one,
T0, and between an x0 and
an x1, where now I have slopes
here that are going to be, in
general, this is
plus 1 minus 1.
And in fact, sometimes it will
be straight, in which case
we'll call it 0.
It's really the inverse of the
slope, but we'll still call it
zero rather than infinity.
So it's 1 over the slope.
There's a name for
that, right?
Is that called the
run or something?
I forget, I don't remember
my calculus.
So that's what we're
going to do.
And we're going to leave the
upper and right borders undone
and include, so it's going
to be a sort of half open
trapezoid on the left and
bottom, closed on the left and
bottom, and open on
the top and right.
So the width is basically the
midpoint here, and the height
is the height, because they're
always going to have
parallel axes here.
So here's how are our recursion
is going to work.
If the height is 1, then we
can compute all space-time
points in any way we want.
I can just go through them if
I want, because they're all
independent.
None depends on anybody else.
So that's going to
be our base case.
If the width is greater than
twice the height, however,
then what we're going to do
is we're going to cut the
trapezoid through the middle
of the slope of minus 1.
And that will produce two new
trapezoids, which we then will
recursively compute all
the elements of.
So I'll start out with
a trapezoid.
Basically, if it ends up that
it's a long and wide one, I'm
going to make what's called a
space cut, and cut it this
way, and then I'm going to
recursively do this one and
then this one.
And notice that I can
do that because--
all these guys I can do, but
then when I get to the border
here, this will already have
been done by the time I'm
computing these guys.
So the requirement is that
I've got to do things
according to that map of triples
that I showed you
before, but I don't have to
do them in the same order.
I don't have to do the whole
bottom row first.
In this case, I can compute the
whole trapezoid here, and
then I can compute this
trapezoid here, and then all
the values that I'll need will
have already been computed
over here, that are on the
boundary of this trapezoid.
The other type of cut I'll
do is what happens when a
trapezoid gets too
tall for me.
So if the trapezoid is too tall,
then what we'll do is
we'll slice it through the
middle, but the other way.
We call that a time cut.
So we won't take it all the way
through time, we'll only
take it partially
through time.
Now you can show, and I'm not
going to show this in detail,
but you can show that if I do
this, my trapezoids are always
sort of medium sized.
I never get long, long
skinny ones.
If I start with something that's
sort of got a good
aspect ratio, I maintain a good
aspect ratio through the
entire code.
So here's the implementation.
This is what Matteo Frigo wrote,
and I've modified it a
little bit.
So basically, we pass in it
the values that let us
identify the trapezoid, t0, t1,
x0, and then the slope on
the left side, x1 in the slope
on the right side, where the
dx0 and the dx1s are all either
0, 1, or minus 1.
And then what I do is I look at
what the height is that my
trapezoid is going
to operate on.
And if the height is 1, well,
then I just run through all
the elements, and I just
compute the kernel--
that program that I showed
you before, that kernel--
on all the elements.
Nothing really to be done there,
just go through and
compute them individually
with a four loop.
Otherwise, if I've got the
situation where the trapezoid
is big, then I do this
comparison, which I promise
you-- you can work out the
math if you wish--
which I promise you tells you
whether or not it's more than
twice the height, as I said
before, whether the width is
more than twice the height.
And if so, I compute the middle
point, and then I
partition it into two
trapezoids, and I
recursively call them.
And otherwise, I simply cut the
time in half, and then I
do the bottom half and
then the upper half.
So getting all those parameters
exactly right takes
a little bit of thinking,
makes my brain hurt, but
Matteo is brilliant at
this kind of coding.
So let's see how
well this does.
So I'm not going to do a
detailed analysis that I did
before, but basically what's
going on is at this level, if
I'm doing divide and conquering,
I'm only doing a
constant amount of work
managing this stuff.
So my caches that I'm taking
in the internal part of the
tree are all going
to be order one.
Now each leaf is going to
represent a trapezoid, which
is going to be approximately h
times w, where h and w are
approximately equal, because
they're going to be shaped--
This is assuming I start out
with a number of iterations to
do that is at least as large as
the number of points that I
have to go on.
If I start out with something
that's really thin and flat,
then it's not going
to be the case.
But if I start out with
something that's deep enough,
then I'm going to be able
to make progress in an
unconventional order into
time by moving the time
non-uniformly through
the space.
So each leaf represents a fairly
balanced trapezoid.
Each leaf basically
is going to--
if you look that the direction
of the trapezoid is in time,
so this represents the spatial
dimension, and if I have
something of size w, I
can access it with
only w over B misses.
And when that fits in cache,
where w is some constant less
than m, so w is order m.
So each of these things that's
a leaf is only going to occur
w over B misses.
Now, the total space number
of points I have to go
after is n times t.
N is going to be the full
dimension this way, t is the
height that way.
And so since each leaf
has hw points, I
have nt over hw leaves.
And the number of internal nodes
is just the leaves minus
1, so they can't contribute
substantially, because there's
only order one misses I'm taking
here, whereas I've got
something on the order of w
over B misses for this.
So therefore, now I
can do my math.
The number of cache misses
I'm going to take is--
well, how many leaves
do I have?
nt over hw.
And what does each
one cost us?
W over B.
And so now, when I multiply that
out, well, hw is about m
squared, and w over B is about m
over B. And so I get nt over
MB as being the total
number of savings.
so whereas the original
algorithm only got nt over B,
we've got this factor of a
memory cache size in there
showing us that we have far
fewer cache misses.
So the cache misses end up not
being an issue for this.
Any questions about that?
So I want to show you a
simulation of this three point
stencil and comparing
the two things.
So this is going to be the
looping version, where the red
dots are where the cache misses
are, and this is going
to be the trapezoidal one.
And basically, I have an n of 95
and a t of 87, and what I'm
going to do is assume a fully
associative LRU cache that
fits four points on a cache
line, where the cache size is
32, two to the fifth as opposed
to two to the 15th,
it's really little.
If I get a cache hit, I'm going
to call it one cycle.
If I get a cache miss, I'm going
to call it 10 cycles.
We're going to race them.
So on the left is the
current world
champion, the looping algorithm.
And on the right is the cache
oblivious trapezoid algorithm.
So let's go.
So you can see that it's
basically, it's made a space
cut there, but it's made a time
cut across the top there.
It said, this is too tall, so
let me cut it this way.
And that guy's, meanwhile,
taking all those-- you can see
how many cache misses
he's taking.
Let's speed him up.
That's one way you can do
it, is make it think.
So let's see what happens if I
have a cache of size eight.
So here we go.
I think I'm just doing
the same thing.
I know I can show
you the cuts.
Can I show you the cuts?
I know.
I think it's because I'm not--
OK, let's try it.
There we go.
Now I'm showing the cuts
as they go on.
Let's do that again.
We'll go fast and do it again.
So those are the cuts that it's
making to begin with as
it's doing the divide
and conquer.
So I think this is the
same size cache.
So now I think I'm doing
a bigger cache.
I think I did a bigger cache,
but I'm not sure I gave the
other guy a bigger cache.
Yeah, because it doesn't matter
for the guy on the
left, right?
As long as the cache line is the
same length and as long as
it's not big enough, he's going
to do the same thing.
He didn't get to take advantage
of the fact that the
cache was bigger, because it
was still smaller than the
array that he's striping
out there.
Anyway, we can play with
these all day.
So if you make the cache lines
bigger, then of course it'll
go faster, because he'll
have fewer misses.
He'll get to bring it in.
So let's see here.
So let's now do it for real.
So this is a two-dimensional
problem.
You can use the same thing
to do what end up being
three-dimensional trapezoids.
In fact, you can generalize
this trapezoid method to
multiple dimensions.
So this is the looping one.
So let's start that one out.
So it's going about 104
frames a minute.
I think by resizing it, the
calibration is off.
But in any case, let's switch to
the cash oblivious version.
Anybody notice something?
Slower.
Why is that?
I gave code exactly
as I had up there.
No, it's not because it's
two dimensions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: I'm sorry?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, so now
it's the trapezoiding at
only 86 frames.
What do you suppose
is going on there?
AUDIENCE: You have
[INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
So this is a case where if you
look at the code I wrote, I
went down to a t, a delta t,
of one in my recursion.
I recursed all the way down.
Let's see what happens if
instead of going all the way
down, playing the trapezoid
game on little tiny
trapezoids, suppose I go down
only to, say, when t is 10,
and then do essentially
the row major ones.
So I'm basically coarsening
the leaves of the thing.
So to do that, I do this.
So now we go--
ah.
So I have to coarsen in
order to overcome the
procedure call overhead.
It has nothing to do
with the cache.
It has to the fact that the
way that you implement
recursion, recursion
and function calls
have a cost to them.
And if what you're going to do
is do a little tiny update of
those few floating point
operations--
let's go back to the looping
just to see.
The looping is going
about 107, 108, and
trapezoiding at 136.
So unfortunately, you need a
voodoo variable, but it's a
voodoo variable not to overcome
the cache, but rather
to deal with what's the
overhead in using the
processor when you do
function calls.
So let's see.
How coarse can we make it?
Let's try five, a coarsening
of five?
That's still pretty good.
How about four?
Still doing 131 frames
a minute.
How about three?
Oh, we lost something there.
How about two?
So at a coarsening of two, I
go 138, whereas the looping
goes at about the same.
I can't do 20.
I didn't program that in.
I just programmed up to 10.
So if I go down to one, however,
then you see it's not
that efficient.
But if I pick any number that's
even slightly larger,
that gives me just enough that
the function call overhead
ends up not being a
substantial cost of the things.
So let me just wrap up now.
So I just have a couple
more things.
So I'm not going to really talk
about these, but there
are lots of cash oblivious
algorithms that have been
discovered in the last 10 or 15
years for doing things like
matrix transposition, which is
similar to rotating a matrix.
You can do that in a cache
oblivious fashion.
Strassen's algorithm, which
does matrix multiplication
using fewer than n
cubed operations.
The FFT can be computed in a
cache oblivious fashion.
And LUD composition
is a popular
thing to solve systems.
In addition, there are cache
oblivious data structures, and
here are just a few of them.
There's cache oblivious B-Trees
and priority queues,
and doing things called
ordered-file maintenance.
There's a whole raft.
There's probably now several
hundred papers written on
cache oblivious algorithms, so
something you should be aware
of and understand how it is that
you go about designing an
algorithm of this nature.
Not all of them are
straightforward.
For example, the FFT one does
divide and conquer but not by
dividing it into two.
It divides it into square root
of n pieces of size square
root of n each in order to get
a good cache efficient
algorithm that doesn't have
any tuning parameters.
But almost all of them, since
they're recursive, do have
this annoying thing that you
have to still coarsen the base
case in order to get really good
performance if you're not
doing a lot of work in the
leaves of the recursion.
So any questions?